Speaker 1: All right. We are following
the continued meltdown in MAGA world
over the Trump FBI raid. This started
Monday night. During our live coverage,
we watched Sean HANNITY absolutely lose it
in some breathless 11 minute monologue about
who even knows what Benghazi and Obama
and due process. Who knows what he was
talking about. This continued yesterday. And
we're going to look at some examples. And you
what's notable about these is obviously
they're running interference for Trump. Now,
there's a couple of things that can be going on.
Some of these folks may themselves be worried that
they could be implicated in the materials found
at Mar a Lago. It's conceivable. The second part
of this is look at how quickly they are willing to
abandon their supposed principles. As soon as they
don't like the way things are going. I'm going to
give you one example here. Here is Charlie Kirk,
seen as a hero to young conservatives around
the country and all this different stuff.
He says, Well, if Trump was raided, then
they should raid Black Lives Matter,
Planned Parenthood and George Soros. Why would you
raid those things? That doesn't make any sense,
Charlie. Well, let's see if he explains it.
Speaker 3: And I'm going to say this
plainly and bluntly. Raids must be met with raids.
They raid Donald Trump's home. Why don't you
go raid BLM for burning down $1,000,000,000
with a property in the summer of 2020?
Speaker 1: So each of those property crimes
is being and has been investigated. And you don't
need a raid if you don't believe that there is
evidence of a crime at a location. Like sometimes
you would just arrest somebody. You know, you
don't necessarily always need a raid in lots of
types of alleged crimes. But why would you start
raiding people? It doesn't make sense, Charlie.
Speaker 3: They raid Donald Trump. Why don't
you go raid Planned Parenthood for all of
their. Let's just say. Very revealing crimes
that was revealed five or six years ago Amara.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Charlie Kirk is referring to a
sort of staged sting operation that was then used
to make false claims about Planned Parenthood.
And there is no reason that today you would start
raiding Planned Parenthood because a legal search
warrant was executed at Donald Trump's home.
Speaker 3: They read Donald Trump. Why does
George Soros get away with everything he's
doing? Funding attorney generals offices?
Speaker 1: Well, funding attorney generals
offices. What crime has taken place, Charlie?
And also, why do they always bring George Soros
into this, these conspiracy theorists, globalist,
internationalist, Trotskyite socialists? Unlike
Obama, Trudeau, Macron and the rest of these,
I'll be biased. Yeah. George Soros.
Charlie, it's a little bit too on the nose,
so all of a sudden, due process going out
the window, just start raiding everybody.
Then there's the planted evidence conspiracy
theory. We already did a segment on that earlier
in the show. But just to be thorough, I am going
to play it again so that we included in this clip
there are ten of these I could play. Here's just
one. This is the planted evidence conspiracy
theory, and I won't subject you to all of
it. Let's just listen to a little bit of it.
Speaker 3: 20 or 30 points. Yes. And she's
part of this. I mean, she is part of the effort
to turn the system into a basically a tyrannical,
anti-conservative, anti Republican constant
violation of the law, which is what the January
six committee is, you know, a fake committee
being covered by the fake news with a fake FBI,
which, by the way, you'll notice they didn't allow
anybody on the Trump side in Tamara Lago. So we
have no idea whether or not they planted evidence.
Yes, that's exactly right. And and Newt,
I have a couple of thoughts. Number one, I
wish I trusted our law enforcement. You need some
form of law enforcement to have a civil society,
but I'm great with you. I say, oh, they're
planting evidence. How disappointing of a place we
are in our country where our immediate reaction
is that our own law enforcement agency might
be planning evidence against a former president.
Speaker 1: There is no such evidence. There is no
reason to believe that they are planting evidence.
There is simply no reason to believe that. And
then here's another talking point that a lot of
them are now stuck to. And that talking point is,
if the FBI can do this to Trump, they could
do this to anyone. No one is safe. This is
a very dumb talking point. And I'll tell you
why in a moment. Here's Tennessee Republican
Senator Marsha Blackburn using this one.
Speaker 3: I think that there are a lot
of questions that we justifiably have and we
want answers, because if the FBI can do this
to President Donald Trump, they can do it
to you. And the American people know that.
Speaker 1: That is such a silly talking point.
What does it mean if they can do it to Trump,
they can do it to you? Is a president, are VIPs,
are wealthy socialites, the elites, whatever
term you want to use the Bilderberg. Now I'm not
doing the Jones thing. Ah, should they be exempt?
Should they get special treatment? And also we
know it can happen to all of us. It happens to
all of us all the time. That's the whole point.
The point is, it doesn't happen to these people at
the top echelons of society. That's why it could
happen to you if it happens that we know it could
happen to us. Marsha. It happens to us all the
time. The question is, will anybody of significant
power actually be held accountable? So brain
worms, a major, major problem with a lot of these
right wing conspiracy theories and maybe the most
brain wormy of them all is the Trump assassination
plot conspiracy theory. It's so wacky. I want to
separate it and talk about it now in its own right